[Musique]
je trouve pièce je paye truc de fou un
truc de beauf pains au chocolat
chocolatines n'incarne pas si un zac une
poche le coffre d'une voiture
la malle d'une voiture voilà bah on va
péter là bas piti la barre est longue
elle est bizarre faire caca qu'allié jeu
cag en cas de lock à bonikro denis légat
keane à fond au taquet à un moment donné
abandonné si tu mets abandonné les
enfants les pitchounets le petit puis
johnny
[Musique]
quoi
oui
tokyo
qui dort
jamais
je suis sûr que la dernière fois que
c'était chez le médecin qui vous a
demandé d'apporter vos radios vous aviez
passé un an ou deux ans auparavant on
n'ait pas retrouvé vos radios donc il a
fallu refaire des radios voilà tout ça
normalement c'est bientôt terminé grâce
à mon espace santé vous allez sur le
site de la caisse d'assurance maladie le
site ameli vous ouvrez votre espace
comme ça toutes vos données biologiques
les prises de sang les radios des
scanners et examens les consultations
seront présents sur ce dossier personne
ne pourra voir ce que vous avez ou
quelles sont les données qui sont à part
votre médecin ou vos médecins si vous
les y autorise et donc vous allez
ameli.fr vous ouvrez mon espace santé
comme ça ça vous évitera de passer dix
fois la même radio parce que des rayons
x et pas forcément très bon pour la
santé et si vous l'avez déjà testé vous
même dites moi ce que vous en pensez
dans les commentaires
stupides
[Musique]